Okay, so good morning. Today we are
doing the gunpowder revolution.
Specifically, we are going to ask the
question
how did Europe, starting about the year
1700,
conquer the world? So,
after the fall of the Roman Empire,
Europe became divided,
very poor, and very weak compared with
the rest of the world.
But then, starting in the year 1700,
Europe very quickly, in only about 200
years time, will go on to conquer the
entire world. So, today we are going to
examine how this happened. Okay.
Um so, before we begin,
I want you guys to remember a very
important concept that we have been
developing throughout this course. And
the concept is this: the nature of the
military determines the nature of the
political system in societies and
nations. Okay? So, the four specific
examples we've looked at are Sparta,
Athens, Macedonia, and Rome. Because
Sparta had a hoplite army, it became an
oligarchy. Okay? Oligarchy means rule by
the few.
The rule by the elite. And hoplites were
farmers who could afford their own armor
and weaponry. Okay?
Um Athens had a navy, and so it was a
democracy.
And the idea here is that anyone and
everyone can row a boat.
And if you
can row a boat, you can fight a war, you
can help Athens win, and therefore you
can participate in the political
process. So, Athens was a democracy.
Macedonia, where Alexander the Great is
from,
um it was a cavalry-based
army.
And because only the nobility could
afford horses, it was a monarchy.
And the last example is Rome. Now, the
thing about Rome that made it distinct
from these societies is that um it was
willing to make tremendous sacrifices on
the battlefield, because it could
replenish its soldiers with allies
from neighboring
nations in the Italian peninsula. And as
such, it was a republic. Now, the
difference between a republic and a
democracy is that in democracy, everyone
has the right to vote, so the decisions
are based on majority
rule, okay? But in a republic, it is
rule by laws and tradition and history.
So, people will do what has been
traditionally accepted as the norm. And
as such, you can bring in immigrants
into your your society very quickly.
This is important for us because Rome
will become the model for America.
Okay? America is not democracy, it is
republic, a very important
um difference. So, I got I want you guys
to remember this idea. The military, the
nature of the military, will determine
the nature of your political system in
your society.
Okay?
All right. So, um let's go over some
basic military history. Um in Greece,
when
uh the poleis were fighting each other,
in very much the same way that the
warring states were fighting each other
in China,
uh the main
uh soldier is called a hoplite. The
hoplite means shield in uh Greek. And
um the thing about the hoplite that's
very important is that it was a
self-sufficient self-sufficient soldier,
meaning that most of the time he was a
farmer, but when there was a war, he
would grab his armor and his shield and
his spear, and he would go to war. You
didn't need a economy
to allow the hoplite to exist, okay?
This This was a self-sufficient system.
Um
Over time, the Macedonians will take the
hoplite formation and turn it into the
Macedonian phalanx.
Um and the Romans will have their
legion.
Okay? Now, the difference between the
Macedonians and the Romans,
uh sorry, the difference between this
um system and the traditional Greek
system is now you have a standing army.
These are professional soldiers that
must be supported by the economy.
Um this is cavalry, the Roman cavalry,
and obviously these are nobility because
only they can afford to have horses.
These are the Vikings that we've studied
before. Again, this is pretty
self-sufficient. The Vikings are able to
build their own ships very quickly and
repair them. And they are able to go off
in small bands. Okay?
Um
the steppe people became archers, right?
So, the Mongol the Mongolians are the
classic example. And again, the thing
here is that
um these people,
ever since they were born, could ride
horses and shoot arrows. And that's why
they were so effective soldiers, and
that's why for the longest time, the
steppe people were the dominant military
force in the world. Okay? They could
come in and conquer all the agricultural
empires. Uh this would include the
Yamnaya, which we talked about, but it
also include
um the Turks and the the Mongolians.
Okay?
Um in medieval Europe, they develop a
new system um where the knight becomes
the main military force in the army.
Now, the knight,
uh as you can see, it requires armored
horses and armored
um and weapons. And this is very
expensive.
And so, and you have to train from an
early age to become a knight. And that's
why you now have a system called
feudalism, where the entire economy
revolves around maintaining knights
for war purposes. Okay? This is where
feudalism comes from.
What makes feudalism stick um is the
idea of castles.
Um so, feudalism
is about decentralization, where the
knights and the lords have control over
the local territory, and there's nothing
the king can do about it. Why? Because
maybe if there's a fight between the
lords and the king, well, and the king
comes with his army, well, the lords can
just hide in their castle. And as you
can see, um
it's very hard to besiege and destroy a
castle. First of all, there's a
defensive perimeter, the moat,
um and then the high walls, okay? And
eventually,
um the king will have to give up.
So, in the feudal system, the king is
more like a figurehead who is appointed
as maybe the chairman
or the elected leader, okay? But the
king does not have that much power over
the local um areas.
This changes
in 1453, okay? In the city of
Constantinople. So, for about close to a
thousand years, Constantinople was the
wealthiest, most powerful city in
Europe. They are the heirs to the Roman
Empire. They consider themselves the
Eastern Roman Empire.
And they are invincible because of their
high walls. Remember, we talked about
the Byzantine Empire before. And for
about a thousand years, Constan-
Constantinople was a was powerful
because they were invincible. You cannot
You cannot besiege the city. Okay? But
in 1453, this changes because the
Ottoman Turks
come in with cannons,
and they lay sie- laid siege to
Constantinople, and they destroy the
walls. And this was unimaginable
before. And so, it's gunpowder that
allows the Ottomans to destroy the once
impenetrable Constantinople. And this
marks a revolution now in Europe. Now,
people understand that you need
gunpowder if you are to win wars in the
future. Okay? This is a revolution now
in Europe. So, over the centuries, what
will happen is this: gunpowder will
radically remake the world in three
fundamental ways.
The first way that's important is
the steppe people cease to be a threat.
Okay? So, for thousands of years, the
steppes, right, the Mongolians, the
Turks, the Yamnaya, they drove history
because they could come in and conquer
empires and establish new societies.
Now, with gunpowder, the cities can
defend themselves against the steppe
people, and eventually, over time, the
Russians will colonize the steppes.
And they will cease to be a factor in
development of global history, okay?
So, this is the end of the steppes.
That's the first fundamental change.
Second is
this will mark the beginning of Europe
as the dominant global power in the
world.
It is China that invents
gunpowder, right? About over a thousand
years ago.
But it is Europe that will perfect
gunpowder as the ultimate military
weapon. And that and it will allow
Europe to defeat everyone, including
Ottoman Turks, including the Chinese.
Um
everyone, okay? The third and most
important fundamental change is that
gunpowder will usher in a whole society
revolution that will remake the fabric
and structure of European society.
Okay? So, I will explain all three as we
move on. But these are the three
fundamental impacts of gunpowder.
All right. Let's talk about um the the
steps. So, before we discuss why the
step people, the Vikings, the borderland
people, they usually tend to win out
against empires, even though empires
have much more resources, much more
people, much more technology, okay?
So, this is the uh chart that explains
why the borderlands wins out in the end.
Because the borderlands have energy. The
people are much more courageous, they're
much more hungry, they're much more
determined. Uh openness. Um the step the
borderlands people tend to be much more
innovative. They're open to new ideas.
They don't invent things, but they take
inventions and they apply it to the
society. The last is opportunistic,
where
um they will only attack you if they
think you're weak, okay?
Uh the empire has three advantages,
mass, organization, and depth. Mass just
means a lot of people. Organization
means a centralized bureaucracy.
And then depth just means that they can
afford to lose a lot of battles.
Okay? And um for most of human history,
the borderlands had advantages over the
empire. But with the advent of
gunpowder,
the dynamic changes. So, now that the
empire is able to control and crush the
borderlands.
The main reason why is with gunpowder
technology, you need organization. You
need centralization.
Remember, before armies were
self-sufficient.
You need to go to war, you told you told
everyone, "Let's go to war." And then
the people who were soldiers would get
their armor and they would rush to
battle, okay? That's what the Greeks did
against the Persians.
But with gunpowder, you need
a professional army, you need engineers,
you need the resources that allow you to
make gunpowder. Okay? So, you need
specialization. With specialization, you
need centralization, hierarchy, and
bureaucracy.
And that's what empires do very well.
And the borderlands don't do this, okay?
And that's why eventually the empires
will win out against the borderlands in
the long term.
All right.
Um
So, there are four major gunpowder
empires, meaning these four societies
are most equipped,
uh most ready to take advantage of the
gunpowder revolution.
The first and most important gunpowder
empire are the Ottomans, right? They're
the ones who took the cannons, the
artillery, and they're the ones who
destroyed Constantinople. And uh the
Ottomans after that became the dominant
power in Europe and the Middle East,
okay? The Ottoman Empire.
Um
what made the Ottoman Empire so fierce
was their use of professional soldiers
called Janissaries. Janissaries are um
young boys who became slave who are
Christian
and they became slaves to the Ottomans.
And they were educated become
professional soldiers. And because they
basically slaves, they owed their entire
loyalty to the Sultan, the king of the
Ottoman Empire.
Okay? And um these are professional
soldiers
who uh made effective very effective use
of gunpowder in battle.
Okay? So, that's the Ottoman Empire. But
then you also have the Mughal Empire,
which was the height of Indian
civilization. They were also for the
longest time a centralized bureaucracy,
and they were also able to take
advantage of gunpowder.
Um then you have the Safavid Empire,
which is in modern-day Iran. They are
the heirs to the Persian Empire. And
remember what you learned last semester
is it was really the Persians who
created bureaucracy
um
in the world, okay?
And of course, the last uh and arguably
most powerful of these gunpowder empires
is China. Okay? This is the Ming Empire.
Uh remember, it was China who invented
the gunpowder.
But what's interesting is
when China invented the gunpowder, it
was not used that effectively. Um the
Chinese army used gunpowder mainly as
bombs or as fireworks, as incendiaries
to blow things up, okay?
It was but because of the Islamic Golden
Age and because of of Genghis Khan's
conquests,
globalization came into being. And this
technology of paper and gunpowder spread
all the way to Europe. It was the
Europeans who
in who innovated gunpowder and turned it
into a propel it.
Okay? It's something like that you shoot
people at, a a projectile. And that's
why we have cannons and um
muskets. And so, it was the Europeans
who actually invented um gunpowder as a
projectile. And then what would happen
is the technology would come back to
China and China would adapt this into
their own army, okay? So, that's that's
that's that's that was the process.
Um
yeah. So, this is China and
uh the use of gunpowder.
Okay. So,
the paradox is this.
It was China who invented the gunpowder.
And the four great gunpowder empires are
the Ottomans, the Safavids, the Mughals,
and the Chinese. But at the end of the
day, it is Europe that conquers the
entire world.
Okay? That's the paradox. That's the
uh mystery that we're looking at today.
And so, the thesis, the answer is
European nations would surpass the
gunpowder empires because they would
adopt a whole society approach to
warfare.
Okay? So, what does that mean?
It means that
um
if you are to have if you are really to
integrate gunpowder into your military
effectively, you need to change the
structure
of your society. You have to change the
status quo.
You have to move from a society that is
heavily centralized to one that is both
centralized and open as well.
Okay?
So, I'm going to explain to you what
changes Europe had to make in order to
um move
to become a modern military. Okay? The
first change
is it went from a feudal system
to a nation-state system.
Okay? Does that make sense? Feudal is
decentralized local powers. Nation-state
is you have a centralized bureaucracy.
Okay? You need that. And that's what
Europe did. Second change is
it went from a focus on villages, on
agriculture, to a focus on towns and
industry.
Right? Because
um with gunpowder, you need specialized
workers, you need engineers, you need
iron workers,
and that happens in towns
and not in villages.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay? Also, when you move to towns, you
start to create
proto-capitalism. So, the merchants
become much more important than the
bureaucrats. Because the merchants who
go and procure
resources necessary for gunpowder. And
the third major change that happened in
Europe that really didn't happen in
anywhere else is a shift in focus from
religion
to science.
Okay? Religion is asking a question,
"What does God want from us? How can we
best serve God?"
Science is is asking a question, "Um how
can we win this war? How can we make
gunpowder much more effective? How can
we kill more people?"
Okay?
So, these are the three major
revolutions that happened in Europe that
really didn't happen in anywhere else.
Okay? And when they happen in Europe, um
it will unleash these extremely violent
and powerful revolutions as well, okay?
Including the French Revolution, which
we will study, the American Revolution.
And it and it it's a bloody process that
takes centuries
to unfold and to develop. But it will
make Europe into the dominant power in
the world, and it will allow Europe to
conquer the entire world and force
nations like China to adopt European
um
social frameworks.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
Okay? So, that's um the main idea here.
Okay. Um the main advantage that Europe
had over the rest of the world was also
its main disadvantage, which was
Europe, ever since the fall of the Roman
Empire, was always divided
and poor and always fighting each other,
okay? This This is what the concept we
use for for this in our classes open
cooperative competition. This is the
main driver of innovation in the world.
When was China most creative? During the
Warring States period, right?
Okay? So, this is this is consistently
true throughout history. Whenever a
society is fractured and the different
constituent parts are forced to fight
each other, this will lead to massive
innovation not just in the military but
also in society, in philosophy, in
literature, okay?
Um so, we talked about the three
revolutions in Europe that came about
because of the gunpowder revolution,
okay?
All right. So, um
one thing to keep in mind is
in the beginning, it was not obvious to
people gunpowder was a revolutionary
force.
Um it would take centuries before
societies, the military use gunpowder as
the main weapon.
Okay, and the reason why is in the
beginning, gunpowder was very unstable.
It was hard to store, it was hard to
make
and
um the guns that you used were too
heavy.
So, they were only a small part
of
your military. Also, what's important
for us to remember is that there's
always been a battle between artillery
and fortification.
Okay? So, even though the Ottomans used
a cannon to destroy Constantinople,
engineers would figure out ways to
better defend the city. Okay, so the
first strategy against um gunpowder was
the idea of earthworks. Basically, and
it's very simple. You just dig trenches
around your city. And then therefore,
the cannons cannot get get come into
range of your city, okay? Does that make
sense? So, there are different
strategies you can use to
um negate the advantage of gunpowder,
okay? So, earthworks is one advantage.
But then, what they figured out was
something called a star fortress, okay?
And this is a another revolution in the
military. A star fortress
is designed differently. Most fortresses
before were rectangular
because because they were the most
intuitive and the easiest to build. But
with a star fortress, you have different
points
in the fortress so that
you even if one part gets destroyed,
guess what? You can fill the gaps.
Right? This part gets gets destroyed,
but then you fill the gaps here.
That part gets destroyed, you fill the
gaps here, okay? So, you basically have
to attack the entire fortress at once.
And most armies don't have these
resources to destroy the entire fortress
at once. You can only do it part by
part.
Okay? You want You want to breach the
fortress, but a star fortress allows you
to be resilient.
Okay? To be flexible.
The The word that we use for this is
ductile, okay? Ductile just means the
resilience of materials.
Um
the gunpowder revolution will also mark
um radical changes in military
formation, organization, and hierarchy.
Okay? So, um again, at this particular
stage gunpowder is only a small fraction
of the entire army. Most people are
using spears and pikes together. Okay?
They also have cavalry as well. So, the
problem for Europeans is how do you best
utilize all these resources
in a much in a efficient and effective
manner, okay?
So, this is one possibility where the
pikes are at the back, the gunpowders
are in the front, and the cavalry is to
the wings, okay? And this provides more
flexibility in your army. And because
Europeans are always fighting each
other, they're always able to figure out
new strategies, okay?
Um this is a picture of an European army
in the
16th century.
Okay? All right, so let's talk about
very quickly
the formation of gunpowder. How is
gunpowder made? Well, gunpowder is made
using three different um resources,
okay?
They are
saltpeter, sulfur, and charcoal.
Charcoal is pretty easy to get.
Okay? Sulfur you get from basically from
volcanoes.
And in Europe, the place where they they
had the most volcanoes was Italy on the
in
Italian peninsula. So, if you look at
the history of Europe, most wars, the
vast majority of wars were actually
fought over the Italian peninsula. One
because you need sulfur for gunpowder,
but also because the Italian peninsula
controlled trade with the rest of the
world, and also because the church was
there, the pope was there.
Okay?
Um
saltpeter
is uh the the the
the technical name is potassium nitrate,
and it comes from manure.
Okay? Manure.
Um it doesn't really grow naturally, so
they have to farm it. They have to make
it. They make it basically by um taking
horse manure animal manure and planting
in the ground and then farming it, okay?
So, this became an industry onto itself.
And saltpeter is important because
um as they
chemically enhance gunpowder, they
discovered that um saltpeter should go
from 41% to almost 70%, okay? So,
saltpeter was the main ingredient in
gunpowder. And the Europeans had to
figure out ways to mass produce
saltpeter. And that's why they came up
with these um uh
nitre okay? Or farms.
Okay? And this became a very important
part of European society.
Um you also had chemists working in
laboratories to better refine
the technology of gunpowder. Okay?
Because because one huge issue with
gunpowder is it's very hard to store.
So, for example
if it rains, guess what? No more
gunpowder, okay? So, they have to
constantly have to refine the chemical
composition of gunpowder to make it
resilient
uh against rain, to make it easier to
store, to make it easier to transport.
There's also good possibility that along
the way
uh the gunpowder um
explodes on you, okay? So, this was an
absolute necessity to figure out how to
better
make, store, and use gunpowder.
Um you also had ironworks, right?
Because you need iron and metal to make
cannons, which was the main use of
gunpowder.
Um these are foundries where they will
make gunpowder. And again
uh this helps us explain why towns
became much more important than
villages, right? Because it's towns
where you have the specialization going
on and not the villages.
Um the thing to remember about the early
guns called the uh arquebus is that
they're very heavy. Now, these are
metal.
Okay? So,
uh the soldier basically needs
something to stabilize the gun. But even
once the gun is stabilized, it's not
very accurate.
Right? You can't It's I mean, you're
better off actually off with a bow and
arrow, and that's what most people were
using, bow bow and arrow, okay?
The other thing about the arquebus and
the musket is it's very very slow.
Right? You have to aim it.
Then you have to fire it, and then you
have to reload it. That could take
uh maybe
10 minutes, half an hour, you know, like
the technology will get better and
better over time, but it's very very
slow. So, you have two issues with the
guns, the musket, the arquebus. One is
that
um it's not very accurate, and second of
all, it's very slow.
So, the only solution is to have mass
army. To have a lot of soldiers firing
at once. So, you don't even care
uh you don't even want to aim. You You
just want to shoot it directly at
cavalry or or soldiers, okay?
And that's the idea. And that's why
um
these armies like the Ming and the
Ottomans were most able to use
gunpowder effectively because they could
organize mass armies, okay? So, the Ming
um were one of the main innovators of
gunpowder armies using something called
a volley, okay? So, what would happen is
soldiers would stand in line, they they
would come up, shoot it, then walk to
the back, and new line would come up and
shoot it again, okay? They weren't
aiming, they were just shooting it. And
this is what we call volley fire.
Right? So, this is the main tactic.
Okay? So, does this make sense to you
guys so far?
Um but over time
um
gunpowder will become will become much
more effective, much more accurate, much
faster.
Okay? And now, what you can do is
conscript more soldiers.
So, in other words, what is required now
is more conscripts for your army, okay?
So, this is a picture
of
um a battle. But not only that, but you
need your soldiers
to be obedient, okay? Because you're
asking them to charge into gunpowder.
Okay? And so, you needed to change the
nature of people
into
basically peace-loving,
pretty
uh simple individuals who were used to
freedom to ones who were obedient, who
were bloodthirsty, and who could kill
other people, okay? And that's why you
have now have the invention of something
called
schools.
Okay? You want to know where schools
come from? It comes from the need to
uh create as many soldiers as possible
for your mass army, okay? So, a concept
that I I want to introduce you today,
and we will go over a lot
in
um
uh
this semester is the idea of
synchronicity, okay? Synchronicity is to
structure to structure your society so
that people in society are able to
follow the rules. Okay? They're able to
follow the rules,
then your society can become much more
prosperous and become
better um
um
uh can have more effective militaries,
okay? So, the two classic examples in
this world of synchronicity, the two
societies that do synchronicity the best
are Germany and Japan.
Okay? Go to Germany, go to Japan. And go
go on the subway. Guess what, guys? Even
though it's really really crowded,
everyone stands in line perfectly.
Okay? Everyone knows his or her position
in the line, and everyone's waiting
willing to wait in line. That's why
um
in the 20th century, Japan and Germany
had such effective militaries, okay? And
also why they also have very effective
industries, okay? Schools, well, it's
it's preparing people not just for the
military, but also for the assembly
line, the workplace.
And again, societies that are most able
to stand in line orderly
will be the most effective in terms of
industry and military. And that's
usually the European societies and Japan
as
well.
Okay? So, again, gunpowder
uh marks a whole society revolution,
changing not just the military and how
how wars are fought, but changing the
very
um nature of what it means to be human.
Okay? Does that make sense?
If you want to know where schools come
from, it comes from the need to fight
wars.
All right? And again,
um
China will adopt all these policies
and struct social structures for itself,
okay?
Um let's go over some wars.
So, what's really important about Europe
at this time, and and why Europe became
the dominant power in the world, is it
never stops fighting
each other, okay? It's always fighting
wars internally and externally against
the Ottomans. Okay, so
um
um the wars between Europe and the
Ottomans are called the
Hungarian-Ottoman Wars, and this will
last for about 300 years.
And in the beginning, this is really
important, is the Ottomans destroy the
Europeans.
The Ottomans are able to destroy
Constantinople, and they're able to take
over most of Eastern Europe. Okay? So,
the Ottomans for many centuries up until
the year 1700 is a dominant military
power in Europe and around the world at
this time.
Um there's also something called the
Hundred Years' War that is fought
between France and England, okay?
Um
let's now go over some some wars, and
what I will do now is show you the
casualty count, like how many people are
killed in action, all right? So, again,
as I mentioned, a lot of wars are being
fought on the Italian Peninsula. So, um
the Second Italian War, there's maybe
200,000 killed during this war, okay?
These are soldiers killed, not
civilians.
But, when you get to a few years few few
years later, it's 31,000.
Okay?
And then it goes up to 30,000,
and then 75,000, okay? These numbers are
going up. Why?
Because the armies are getting larger,
and the weapons are getting much more
precise and effective, okay? The This is
the reason why
uh
more people are dying.
The English-Spanish War, it is really
important um 48,000 people died. This is
important because, remember last class
we talked about about how Spain is a
dominant naval power in the world, and
that's what what allowed Spain to
colonize South America. But, um in this
war,
England will destroy the Spanish Armada,
the Spanish the Spanish navy. And
England now will become the dominant
navy
in Europe and around the world. And they
will maintain this position until
America and World War II, okay?
So, this is a really pivotal point in
history, the sinking of the Spanish
Armada by the by the English.
We said this 30 years before,
um which was a religious war between the
Protestants Protestant Europe and the
Catholics. This will kill between 4.5
million
to 8 million people over a span of 30
years. This is the worst war in Europe
before World War I. Okay? So, these wars
are becoming much more violent, much
more
uh deadly.
Um Spanish-Portuguese War, 80,000.
Franco-Spanish War, 108,000. Okay?
You're seeing these numbers go up,
right?
Franco-Dutch War, 242,000.
Uh
War of the Holy League, it's almost
400,000. This is important because this
is when Europe is finally able to defeat
the Ottoman Empire. This marks a radical
turning point where Europe will now
become the dominant military power in
the world, and the Ottomans will now
decline rapidly. Okay? Now, you may be
asking yourself, "Wait a minute here.
Why are all these wars being fought?"
And the answer is
um Europe is divided among different
kingdoms.
And the main policy of all these
kingdoms is balance of power.
So, whenever a new power arises, the
other powers get together and try to
take down that empire, okay? So, before
it was Spain,
and then Spain was destroyed, then it
was France,
then it was Russia, then it was Germany,
okay?
So, that's the idea here.
Um Nine Years' War,
almost 700,000.
The Seven Years' War is really the first
world war because it's a war fought
between France and England for control
of the entire world, okay? It's being
fought in North America, and it's being
fought in Europe. And almost a million
people get killed in this war over 7
years.
French Revolutionary Wars, we'll discuss
this later on,
but 663,000 killed. The French
Revolutionary Wars is important
historically because
a lot of people who fought in this war,
they are not professional soldiers.
They're just citizens who have
revolutionary devotion and fever. They
love their country, they want freedom
for the country, so they take up arms,
and they're able to defeat more powerful
European adversaries.
Guys, so this is the this is the
beginning of what we call the
nation-state, when a citizen is
completely loyal to the nation. All
right? We'll be talking about this
um
later on, the French Revolutionary Wars.
The And then, of course, the climax is
World War I, and you count 20 million
people,
okay? 20 million people die in this war.
So, you can see how the casualty rates
just go up exponentially over the
decades. And that just shows you how
fast the Europeans are innovating, okay?
They're innovating in terms of
bureaucracy, meaning that they're able
to tax their citizens much more
effectively.
They're able to conscript more soldiers
effectively. They're also innovating in
terms of technology
because of science, right? They now have
like machine guns.
In
uh World War I, they also have trenches.
We'll We'll talk about talk about this
later on.
All right. So, as I said before, um the
thing about Europe is that it's always
divided into different factions who are
always fighting against each other. And
what you will see what what these maps
will show you is two things. First is
that
um
the status quo is always switching back
and forth between different nations,
okay? So, in the beginning in 1448, the
Holy Roman Roman Empire is a dominant
power in Europe with a population of 15
million people, okay? That's the first
thing I want you guys to notice about
these maps. Um the dominant power is
always changing over time. The second
thing that you will notice is that even
though, this is really interesting, even
though these wars are deadly, they're
continuous,
and they're becoming much more violent,
the population of every nation in Europe
goes up over time.
Okay?
So,
um 1554, the Ottomans now are in
control, and they're at 24 million. The
Holy Roman Roman Empire goes down to 19
million, but France is arising, so is
Russia.
Okay?
1623,
uh
the Holy Roman Roman Empire
uh is still around. So, Holy Holy Roman
Empire and Ottomans are the dominant
powers. But, by the time
of 1660 1660, France actually becomes
the dominant power
in Europe. And because France becomes
the dominant power in Europe, all the
nations decide to go against France.
Okay? And this leads to a series of
wars.
Um
1727, France has has 23 million. That
matches the population of the Ottomans.
Russia is rising now.
Okay?
Right before the French Revolution,
1780,
France is now the most populous country
in
Europe, okay? 27 million. The Ottomans
have 26 million, okay?
And this And this is right before the
French Revolution.
1824, the Russians are now at 49
million. They become now the dominant
military power in Europe. And this will
bring them in conflict with the rest of
Europe. Okay? So, England and Russia
will fight in what they call the Great
Game. We'll We'll be going over this in
in a future class, okay? So, the rivalry
between
the United Kingdom and Russia, which
still goes on today, by the way, okay?
It It's still going on today, the Great
Game.
Um
Germany is now rising in 1890, okay?
This is right before World War I.
And so, Germany now is a dominant power
in Europe. So, guess what happens?
All the nations in Europe combine
together
to attack Germany. And this leads to
something called World War I.
Okay?
All right? So, that's the
quick introduction to
uh the history of
the military revolution in Europe, okay?
We'll be going into specifics in future
classes. All right. Any questions?
About this?
Was Was Was this clear to you guys?
Okay, any questions?
Every time in a war, they kill so many
people, and especially for the
male labor in the society, how can they
recover from such a hurt every time?
Okay, great question, okay? So, the
question is
um these wars are so deadly, right?
And so, how's it possible
for these societies to be resilient and
to recover?
Okay, um so
um there are many different reasons
there there are many many factors going
on, okay? But
what's important is the rise of
something called the nation-state.
Okay? So, the nation-state replaces the
role of religion in people's lives.
Right? Before, you had to
sacrifice your life to the will of God.
You had to serve God.
Now, with the French Revolution, you now
have to dedicate your life to the
nation.
Okay? The glory of the nation. What And
what does that mean? It means that you
have to do whatever it takes in order
for your nation to beat other nations in
war, which includes
um
um working hard, making a lot of money,
but also includes basically having a lot
of children.
And this is facilitated by the
scientific and agricultural revolution.
Remember last class we talked about how
um because of the Age of Exploration,
the Europeans were able to bring back
the potato,
corn,
tomatoes,
squash. These are pretty easy to grow,
and they provide a lot of nutrition for
the European nations, okay?
But um what But what's important is
what's really driving the population
growth is war
and the necessity for having a large
population. So, the government will
provide a lot of policies
that promote population growth,
Does that make sense? We'll We'll We'll
be dis- discussing this in future
classes.
All right? And
I mean
I I know it's
hard for us to imagine,
but war gives people meaning and
purpose.
Okay? Does that make sense? It's It's
like it it it's like rooting for a
sports team. You want your sports team
to win, no matter what.
Okay? You're You're You're You're going
to go and cheer them on. Okay? That's
what war does. War really galvanizes
the energy of people.
So, people feel extremely patriotic
during wars, even though their children
are getting killed. The other thing
that's really important about war
um is that
it gives people hope in the future. I I
know this is paradoxical, okay? But So,
let me explain.
With war, a lot of people die.
With death comes op- opportunities that
didn't exist before.
That creates social mobility.
So, it's perfectly possible that you're
a peasant, but because of war, the
nobility dies off, and your son can go
join the army, become like a captain or
lieutenant, come back and start his own
business.
And that wasn't available before, right?
Because in peacetime, the social
hierarchy stays stagnant.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, um yeah, I I mean like And And so,
if you think about it, it's because we
live in a world of peace,
okay? Something called the Pax
Americana, the American peace.
And that's why a lot of young people
refuse to have children. Okay? Why are
young people refusing to have children?
They really don't see a future, right?
It's like
I'm not going to rise up in the social
hierarchy. The My kids aren't going to
rise up in the social social social
social hierarchy. There are fewer fewer
economic opportunities.
Your old people aren't dying,
okay?
They're not dying. I mean, I know a lot
of old people who are extremely
successful, and they will live over 100.
They are like 90, 80 right now, and they
are extremely healthy. They're happy
with their lives.
They're very wealthy. They don't have a
They don't have any reason to die.
And they won't die.
So,
all that wealth becomes monopolized by
old people, and so young people are
like,
"Why would I want to have children? Why
would I want to work hard?
Why Why do I even want to be ambitious?
There's no point."
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay, all right.
Good. Great question. An- An- Any more
questions be- before I continue?
All right. So, what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to summarize
what we learned, okay?
Um just so you have a clear
clear understanding of how everything
fits together. All right.
So, feudalism. What is feudalism?
This is a system that was in Europe
for 100 years, okay? In something called
the High Middle Ages or the Late Middle
Ages, which was maybe about a thou- the
year 1000 to 1400, okay? 1500, okay? So,
how does feudalism work? Feudalism works
because
each part of society is partitioned into
different lands run by lords, okay?
Maybe Lord A, Lord B, Lord C, Lord D.
And the king was more of a figurehead.
And he really didn't have that much
authority over the local regions because
each region has their own army with
castles. So, it's very hard to invade
every single part, okay? And so,
um whenever there's a war, what happened
is the king says, "Okay, guys, we need
to go to war." So, A would come in with
his army, B would come in with his with
his army, then C,
then D. And they would fight
independently, okay? And what often
happen is that maybe
C betrays the king, okay? This would
happen a a lot in European history. But
this is how most wars are fought um
in the feudal era, okay? Now, with the
gunpowder,
okay? With gunpowder,
okay? You need centralization.
Why? Because the thing about gunpowder,
as I discussed, is you need a huge army
in order to best effectively use this
gunpowder. So, you need two things:
taxation
and conscription.
And therefore, you need a bureaucracy.
Okay?
Does that make sense, guys? You need to
do resolve these two issues. You have to
tax people
to create a central army,
and you need to conscript people to fill
the ranks of your army. And you can only
do it through a centralized bureaucracy.
Therefore,
at this time, historians say that the
feudalism transitioned into an absolute
monarchy, where the king now has
absolute power. Because the king Only
the king can organize a centralized
bureaucracy.
Okay?
So, now, what happened is that um the
king
would ask for conscripts from all lands
to create a centralized
army.
Okay?
So,
why you need to do this
is the nature of gunpowder.
So, remember before,
um
soldiers were self-sufficient. If
there's a battle, they just went and got
their armor, and then the sword, and
then they'd go off to battle, okay? With
gunpowder, you need different elements,
okay? First of all, you need material.
The The two main materials are sulfur
and um
saltpeter.
And therefore, you needed to do trade
and production.
Okay? You needed to create a gunpowder
economy if you were to have a gunpowder
army.
But you also need
um specialists.
Specialists are just people who are able
to make gunpowder and who are able to
use gunpowder in battle.
Okay? You need
industry.
Industry are people who manufacture
gunpowder and manufacture cannons.
You need
research. And these are just scientists
who help you refine gunpowder
over time. Okay?
You also need a bureaucracy
to coordinate.
And you also need a military hierarchy.
Why? Because
these soldiers need to be trained on how
to how to use the guns.
Okay? You so you need a hierarchy
to control the training of soldiers and
the deployment of soldiers in battle.
Okay? So So I mean, like this is very
simple
um what what I'm doing. But as you can
see,
what this means is you need a what I
call a whole
society approach.
Okay?
You have to
radically transform your society
so that it is
all resources are directed to the use of
gunpowder in battle. And the society
that is most able to do this
will be the most effective
in war, okay? And who are the who are
the
people who are most able to do this over
time? The Prussians, which will become
Germany, and the Japanese, okay? And
these these are just two examples. Also
the Americans as well. And they are the
most effective in in war. A whole
society approach.
Now, the question then is
well, okay, the logic here makes sense,
but why is it
that it's Europe that used a whole
society approach and not China?
Not the Ottomans,
not the Indians, okay? And the reason
why is whole society approach means a
radical transformation
of your social hierarchy and social
order.
That's the reason why.
All right? So the three major changes as
we discussed is to go from feudalism,
okay, basically an aristocracy,
to
a bureaucracy, okay? A national
bureaucracy, bureaucrats. So the power
shifts from the aristocrats
to the bureaucrats.
Okay? That's one radical social change.
But then you have to go from
um agriculture
to industry.
It who? The merchants.
So now you have to give the merchants,
the capitalists, trades people, more
power in your society.
Right? And the And
the bureaucrats don't want that.
Okay?
And then you have to go from religion
to science. So now
the people with the most authority in
your society are no longer priests,
which has historically been true, but
scientists.
Right? So this is a radical
social transformation that overturns the
entire social hierarchy. And that's why
And that's why, this is really
important, this is a process that will
take centuries and which will lead to
traumatic social revolution, including
the French Revolution and American
Revolutions, okay? We'll be discussing
this later on.
Okay? So
that's what you have to do. And most
societies are not willing to do this
because
the elite don't want to give up power,
okay? It's that simple, okay? The elite
do not want to give up power, their
power has to be taken away from them.
Okay? So
let me give you an example to illustrate
how hard it is to
transform society, okay? All right. So
let's look at China.
Let's look at Europe.
Hey guys.
So China is
um one of the first societies to
centralize. And when you centralize, you
um
accumulate a lot of resources, and these
resources allow you to make great
inventions. And so the four great
inventions of China are the compass,
right?
Paper,
printmaking,
and um gunpowder. Okay, these are the
four great inventions
of China. China was
the first to invent this by hundreds of
years, okay?
So the printing press in China was maybe
around the year 800.
In Europe it'll be 1400, okay? So this
is like a huge advantage over Europe.
But these four inventions did not really
impact society in China. They had no
impact on society. But in Europe, when
they are when they go over to Europe,
the compass will bring in
the Age of Exploration, right? It will
allow Europe to conquer the entire
world. The Age of Exploration.
Right? Paper and printmaking, what does
it do? It creates universal literacy.
Everyone in Europe is now able to read
and write because of paper and
printmaking. It radically transforms the
entire
fabric of European society. And And
because people are now able to read and
write, it gives rise to the Renaissance,
the Protestant Reformation, the
Scientific Revolution, okay?
And the gunpowder allows Europe to
conquer the entire world. Conquest.
Okay?
So think about that. You're China was
the first to invent all four,
and Europe was able to take all four and
radically transform the society and make
Europe into the dominant power in the
entire world.
Right? So then the question then is
why is it
China didn't make use
of these four inventions? Let's look at
paper and printmaking, okay?
The problem in China is that you have
these Confucian bureaucrats.
And what is their source of power? It's
the monopoly over literacy and knowledge
production, right? So they didn't want
to make
it possible for everyone to read and
write because that would
reduce their power over the people,
right?
Does that make sense?
Same with the compass. The compass would
allow China to explore the world and
bring in new ideas and new goods. The
bureaucrats didn't want that. They want
to protect the social hierarchy.
With gunpowder, yes, it's fine, but the
problem is
if now everyone has a gun,
they can revolt against you, right?
Okay? So for China, it was much more
important to maintain the social
hierarchy
than it is to innovate and to dominate
the world.
In fact, what's important for us to
remember is that if you give governments
a choice,
they would always choose to maintain the
social hierarchy rather than to to
innovate because that's just the easiest
thing to do.
But, and this is important, Europe
didn't have a choice in the matter. It
was a matter of life and death. You
either innovate or you will get
destroyed by your neighbor.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay.
Great.
Okay. So um
So we we we did a broad overview of the
history, and we'll go in go into very
specific details um
over the next few weeks, okay? So next
class will be on the Enlightenment,
which will then give rise to the French
Revolution and the American Revolution,
okay?
All right? So but this is just a very
broad overview.
All right. So
questions, guys.
Yes.
Okay. So why did Europe innovate, right?
Okay. Great. So let's look at
Europe.
Like let's just look at France or
Okay.
Okay. So as a nation,
you are under two types of pressure.
External.
Okay?
External just means Britain,
Russia,
Germany,
Holy Roman Empire.
Okay? You have a lot of enemies.
Okay?
And so you're competing against them.
At the same time, this is really
important,
you have
Sorry.
Um
internal
pressure as well, okay?
Because remember,
what they're doing now is they're
recruiting more and more people to join
your army.
And the general rule is that if you will
fight for you,
if they die for you, they also have a
say
in your society.
Okay?
Also, you need you need you need you
need to get people to have children
to replenish your population.
You need everyone to get get get You
need to get them to work hard, okay?
So you're always afraid of revolution,
discontent,
and also the idea of indifference,
right?
People don't care anymore.
So, you're under these two pressures.
So, because of these two pressures, it
creates contradictions in your society.
And these contradictions force you to
balance these contradictions, which
leads to innovation.
Okay? Does the logic here make sense to
you? Right? This creates conflict and
contradiction.
Right?
Which will then lead to
uh innovation.
And if you don't do If you don't
innovate, then you have a revolution
or defeat, okay?
Does that make sense? If you don't
innovate, your enemies will come and
conquer you, or your people will rebel
and overthrow you, okay? Those are the
two options. You don't have a So, you
don't have a choice in the matter but to
innovate.
But sometimes
the innovation can keep up with the
social change.
And that's what happened in the French
Revolution, which will which will we
will discuss
uh later on, is that, okay, the
government was trying to make these
changes, but you have too many social
classes, the merchant class,
uh
the educated middle class, lawyers,
basically. You you have all these
different social groups now who want a
greater say in government,
but then you have this hierarchy of like
clergy, nobility,
um and
um the bureaucrats who want to maintain
their privileges.
Okay? And if you can't resolve this
conflict, then the only
outcome is revolution.
All right? So So,
it's either you choose to resolve it, or
it will be resolved for you, okay?
So,
this is a
process of constant
innovation and revolution, okay?
But yeah? I understand.
So,
didn't China have the same problem? But
didn't they have enemies or
I mean, I I think they have revolutions.
I mean, like they they always have like
revolution that have different
dynasties.
Okay. All right. Um that's a good
question, okay? So, why is this
happening in China? Okay.
All right. So, um the first thing about
China that's different from Europe is
that China for the longest time has been
much more united. And there are natural
boundaries that protect China, okay? So,
the sea, the mountains, the desert to
the north, okay? So, China has these
natural boundaries that Europe doesn't
have.
Um so, from the perspective of Chinese
bureaucrats, they're not afraid of
external enemies, okay? Because like
Japan, Korea, they're not really threats
to China at this time. They're more
afraid of internal revolution.
Okay? So, that's that's where the focus
is is on like, how do we maintain
internal coherence? And the best way to
do that is by co-opting the local elite,
by bribing the local elite.
Okay? And the best way to bribe the
local elite is by
helping them stamp out local discontent,
ensuring that the people that are most
loyal to you are always in power in
local areas.
Okay?
Does that make sense? So, um So, the
example is this. Example is
think back to uh the Japanese invasion
of China, okay? World War II.
You look at the KMT, the Kuomintang,
which is the dominant power
in China.
Japan is coming in, conquering most of
China, controlling the industrial
heartland.
And what is Chiang Kai-shek
doing?
Does he care about the Japanese? Not at
all. He cares about the Communist Party.
These peasants in these caves in
northwest China.
Why?
The Japanese are a much more
a are much greater military threat, but
they are not a threat to the social
hierarchy. You can work with the
Japanese, right? The Japanese are
perfectly willing to work with you to
control China.
The Communists represent an overturning
of the social hierarchy. Therefore, they
are a much greater threat.
Okay? That Does that make sense? But
that's a logic um
in China. Okay? Maintain the social
hierarchy. If foreigners want to come
and conquer China, that's fine because
we can work with them to maintain the
social hierarchy.
Okay? But
uh these peasant rebels are the real
problem.
Okay?
Um so,
if the Chinese are already trying their
best for the stabilization, why are our
dynasties still not lasting long or
stable?
If they like they are only valued for
the social hierarchy, but they are
actually not minding that which emperor
is exactly who it is.
Yeah. Okay. So, that's a good question,
okay? Um
Why is it that Chinese dynasties don't
last very long, right? Okay.
So,
I I
I know this is hard to understand, uh
but what what Chinese civilization is,
it's
bur- it's it's a bureaucracy.
Okay?
Bureaucracy.
Because the bureaucracy represents a
social hierarchy.
Okay?
Confucianism.
If the Confucian culture
lives on,
China lives on.
So, what's important is to protect the
Confucian culture, which puts scholar
officials or bureaucrats at the top of
society.
So, you can have the Mongols, you can
have the Japanese, you can have, I don't
know, Zhu Yuanzhang, who cares? The
emperor doesn't matter.
You understand? The emperor doesn't
really matter in this system. What
matters is the bureaucracy.
And that has been consistent for 2,000
years.
Okay? Does that make sense? Okay, so so
the intention, the strategy is to
maintain the bureaucracy, even though
you may need to put in a foreign leader.
Okay? In fact, you're better off with a
foreign leader because the foreign
leader is much more dependent on the
bureaucracy than maybe a local leader.
So, they actually don't care about who
it is, the emperor, right?
Yeah, it doesn't matter. The The emperor
is just a figurehead.
The emperor has has no power, right?
Because you think about it, the emperor
is just one person.
But the information that he gets is all
from bureaucrats.
And therefore,
you can control and manipulate the
emperor
based on the information you provide
him.
Right? So, it's a bureaucracy that has
all the power.
And that's why China doesn't innovate,
because the bureaucracy is too powerful.
Okay?
Does it Does that make sense?
Okay, great.
Questions? So, like um European
countries were all like kind of related
with each other in some way. Like their
nobilities are
intermarried Yeah. or brother or
sisters. Yeah. So, why didn't they like
think about unite unification, like?
Yeah. Okay, so that's a great question,
okay? So, the thing thing about the
European nations is that even though
they're divided,
they um
are basically one big family, okay? Like
so, for example, the Germans, the
Russians, the English, they were just
like one big family. They were cousins
of each other, but they still went to
war, and they still killed millions of
people.
Okay? Um So, how do we explain this?
And the answer is
um
we we can use game theory, okay?
Game theory.
The native game theory is that
you can be related to each other, but
you're all participants in a game in
which you're they're going to be one
winner.
Right? So, um
um
you still
have to think about your own survival.
And you can survive as long as you have
the
if as long as you have authority and
legitimacy among your people.
Right? Because if if they think that you
are representing a foreign interest,
your soldiers won't be loyal to you.
They'll They'll kill you.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay? And also like like look look,
there's a very common, very simple
uh example where it's very common
that a king dies,
right? And guess what what? The two sons
start a civil war.
Right? They're brothers.
But why are they fighting a civil war?
And the reason why is, okay, and this is
really interesting, is they represent
different political factions
who are all striving for power.
And the sons
are just figureheads for these political
factions.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay?
Okay? So, civil wars are fought between
different political factions,
and they will appoint maybe son A
to be the head, okay?
And son A,
if he doesn't agree, they'll find
someone else.
Okay?
So, everyone's trying to be the top dog.
Everyone's It It's really
Okay, yeah. So, So, there's a theory,
but the theory is called status.
What we really want is status.
Right? And so, um brothers hate each
other the most because only one can have
status. The other must
obey.
And that's why
uh throughout history, so much violence
has been between princes.
Okay?
Who are striving for this top top
position. So, so so they're different
theories.
Okay?
Great. Any more questions?
You mentioned that
in Europe,
schools were
were
institutions that create soldiers.
And that's kind of like not the case in
China where
like Confucius
and all that
academy
in China. And then you mentioned that
later on,
China also adopted the
European ways.
Okay.
So, let's go over the history of
schooling, okay?
So, the modern schooling model that we
use today is from Prussia.
Okay, Prussia.
Okay, schools.
Okay, and so
if you are in military, you need
soldiers.
And what you discover is if you want
soldiers to be obedient,
you need to train them from an early
age.
But not only that, but you need to
separate them from their families at an
early age. Okay, does that make sense?
Because if they are separate from their
families, they feel more anxious, they
feel more stressed, they're less loved.
Therefore, they're much willing to
accept authority.
And they're much more willing to kill
other people, okay? So, that's a basic
theory of schooling.
Um make them obedient from an early age,
and separate them from their families
from an early age, and then uh train
them to be a soldiers from an early age,
okay?
That And this is a model that we adopt
for today universal schooling. And every
country uses the system because not only
is it good for the military, it's also
good for industry, right?
Companies also want this system where
you go in and you work hard because
you're anxious. You want to make money.
You want to prove yourself.
Right? Whereas if you feel loved by your
family, you don't care. You're like, you
know, like I don't like this boss. I'm
I'm going to go home and be with my
mother.
Okay? So, um that's why every nation
adopted this system because it's it's it
was invented for the military, but it
really helps with the industry, okay?
So, the question then is, why did China
adopt this? Well, because of industry,
right?
Because China needs factory workers. And
this system gives you the best factory
workers.
Okay? Does it make sense?
Great.
Any more questions?
Okay. So, great questions, guys. Um I
really enjoy it when when when you ask
questions. And And like they're really
perceptive, okay? And I think that by
asking them,
you learn a lot as well. So, um next
class we do the enlightenment.
Okay? And this will pave the way for the
American and the French Revolutions.
Um there's no class next week because of
midterms, but I'll see you after the
after the midterms, okay?
Okay.